[Applause]
it's interesting with these well
disguised arranged like a Georges Braque
say shame
you Durante all right
good night mrs. calabash Jim wherever
this would be a good place to meet and
exchange microfilm when communism the
botanical garden who are on a Thursday
afternoon
[Music]
I
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so from your interest in Eastern
philosophy you somehow made a bridge to
an interest in comedy and performance
how did that I think it was the other
way around that my interest in comedy
sort of led me into philosophy and
looking for the the real jesters in the
philosophical world led me to my on a
Buddhism led me to the Daoists Sufis
possible fees of course yes and and I
think there's a lot of Western artists
and philosophers who are crazy wisdom
masters of course Nietzsche and the
Dadaists hieronymus pas Hieronymus Bosch
Mark Twain you know Mark Twain's dark
writing so-called dark writings a
wonderful sort of deconstruction a
humorous deconstruction of Christianity
and Western God I remember he wrote a
short novel on the subject of the
courtly fart he was a classic but and I
think he was sort of the Western Shuang
soo Kwang soo is very much like Mark
Twain Shuang sue said he you know Z as a
fool is not the biggest fool and that's
sort of the crazy wisdom outlook is that
we really take ourselves very seriously
and maybe there's no reason to take
ourselves seriously we should think
about it well this sounds a little like
the classical cartoon the guy coming to
mr. natural and saying what does it all
mean mr. Nash and they says it don't
mean do do you got it that's there are
some crazy wisdom masters though who
sort of transcend that view and and they
have they have a more benign feeling
about the human condition but there are
those who
coming out of the crazy wisdom school
you might say although they they would
Alton either in a school who think that
life is is pretty much meaningless and
it's at the joke's on us I mean here we
are born into a life we didn't ask for
not told why we were here what we're
supposed to be doing and given just
enough awareness to know that we exist
then that we're gonna die it's like wavy
gravy says if you don't have a sense of
humor it's just not funny
yes well didn't somebody say life is a
joke without a punchline and death is a
punchline without a joke Franz Kafka you
know if it once that though the meaning
of life is that it stops yes it's great
did you see here in Prague that one of
the main streets has a banner with
Kafka's name across it because they're
doing some theater production and I
thought to myself if that isn't Kafka
what is so we've been talking about your
interest in Mahayana I know your main
interest is comedy and humor as the
author of crazy wisdom can you put those
two things together for us yeah it's a
it's sort of like a cosmic perspective
in a comic perspective or one of the
same if you get the right angle on the
human condition you know and there are
many great fools and gestures who have
also been mystics and have really had
the overview of overviews and yet make a
lot of jokes and make light of it it's
sort of the lighter side of
enlightenment you might say so you mean
the great Mad Men of Western history
Hieronymus Bosch Dali and sore Mark
Twain Mark Twain Groucho Marx I mean you
name it there's a there's a million of
them and they're both Western and
Eastern and they they both
all the crazy wisdom masters seem to say
that you know this this life is it is an
enigma and if it's not an enigma what is
it you know so if you can't understand
it at least you can laugh at it
yes trying to laugh through the tears I
mean that's been the the ancient Jewish
Jewish way through their all their
oppression and being a Jew born and
raised in Nebraska life has always been
a little strange for me you know I've
always felt a little like an alien I was
going to say an extra environmental for
sure fish i'm talking with scoop miss
kerr the author of crazy wisdom well now
your your métier tends toward
performance is that right actually
partially performance not a lot of
people get my jokes it's mostly
transpersonal people that get my jokes
so i do workshops mostly in crazy wisdom
sometimes with Paul Krassner the editor
the realist we have workshop
participants make up their own religions
and their own governments and then
present some kind of ritual that would
would give the facets of that government
or religion so basically it sounds like
the premise of crazy wisdom is a
reference and breaking down of
boundaries surrounding sacred cows and
institutions absolutely and and saying
that you know we really don't know and
we have to look at all of our stories
and see them all as only possibilities
and and that nobody's got the the answer
and also that you know we think so much
of ourselves we take ourselves so
seriously and we think we know what's
going on but every century or so or in
every new civilization we find out the
previous one was wrong and so to
recognize as Chuang Tzu says that they
who know they are fools are not the
biggest fools you know so would you be
willing to sign on to the idea that the
world is not only stranger than we
suppose it's strange even Lee
and suppose yes yes I don't do that good
well listen can we have a hit of you're
sure [ __ ] here let me step away and you
just to do your thing
that's your bag that's my face well I'll
sing a little song of introduction our
crystal a mystical I like brown rice
I got myself a mom trap try to encounter
of meditation set me free you can tell
by the things I do I'm a middle-class
Jew
it's uh it's been great being here in
Prague where they've had this Velvet
Revolution it just it's so soft so soft
and beautiful to look at and they have
this president that we in America can
only like dream up box loft problem you
know a philosopher a poet a conscious
compassionate man George Bush was
formerly in the oil business and the
president we had before that was a
b-grade movie actor so they had a Velvet
Revolution here we're still waiting for
our revolution in the United States the
polyester revolution when the when the
Soviet empire collapsed I said to myself
haha
one Empire down one to go and it won't
be long it seems like it seems like the
United States decline and fall is well
underway there's really nothing to be
ashamed of
empires all flaps no Empire can live
forever
a couple decades ago the British we're
proud to say looking over their vast
empire the Sun never sets on the British
Empire and now it's just those few
little islands in the North Atlantic
they might say the Sun never Rises on
the British Empire so that's it's the
fate of all empires and ours is on on
the decline real steep these days you
know the biggest national debt in
history the biggest trade deficit in
history
the Japanese make better cars and TV
sets than we do the French make better
bottled water than we do God knows the
czechoslovakians make better beer than
we do I think what we should do is see
the writing on the wall and go to the
United Nations and announce that we are
resigning formerly as a superpower and
from now on I would like to be known as
an ordinary nation and just saves
everybody the trouble of decline and
fall that would really would be it would
set an example for all empires to follow
I think it's really a good idea and
there's a candidate for president who
could lead us in this decline and fall
make it easy for us my friend here
nobody nobody lower your taxes nobody
will feed the poor and nobody can fix
the economy because nobody's minding the
store and nobody has all the answers
nobody can stop the wars when nobody
wins nobody loses because nobody is
keeping score and nobody is going to do
it for you and nobody will teach you
fail because nobody knows the trouble
you see and nobody cares and
one more thing nobody is perfect and
nobody will live forever and nobody's
going to save you nobody knows what's
going on and nobody is the one and only
one well one more thing nobody loves you
Oh nobody could be so divine and nobody
could fool all the people all the time
well the transpersonal conference that's
what we're here in Prague for and really
what it's all about is breaking out of
your personal trance transpersonal is
breaking out of your personal trance and
into the cosmic dance and you do this by
breathing hard and fast and
hyperventilating or by taking psilocybin
mushrooms and having a vision or by
taking a hero's journey or a shamans
journey or taking a course in miracles'
developing your imagination your mythic
imagination your intuition getting in
touch with your heart chakra your right
hemisphere of your brain until you can
see the implicit order and you can smell
the morphic resonance and you can feel
yourself dissolve into the the ultimate
hologram of the universal ground of
being and learn to love at all as you do
yourself that's transpersonal and it's
breaking out of your personal trance and
into the cosmic dance because really you
know we are all one i'm one anyway i
think you're probably one too and you
know those those people who achieve
oneness can then move on to tunis
something like that anyway we are all
made of the same stuff as you can see
you know there's grass here and
trees and if you go inside of those bed
grass and trees you'll find subatomic
particles that are the same as the
subatomic particles inside of me what
else is there to say I mean we are all
one and you know you can have this
cosmic perspective you know the Big Bang
and everything expanding away from
everything else and at all eventually
coming back again into this one little
particle that it all came out of and you
can have the great perspective of the
betta sits there with his little smile
watching empires rise and fall and
individuals rise and fall and even
universes rise and fall everything's
born and transforming into something
else and nothing remains as it is and
the Buddha knows this and yet he's got
this little smile on his face sort of a
little smaller than that of Alfred e
Newman's who's once said what me worry
sort of like that but a little bit
smaller of a smile but no matter how big
a cosmic perspective you are he's got
sometimes you get the blues because
everybody gets the blues and life is
tough you know it's just it's just that
way you know the Hasidic rabbis used to
say if God lived on earth people would
break out all his windows so I'd like to
close maybe here with a little song
called the Buddha News
[Music]
woke up this morning in my mind I tried
some medication but no peace good I find
call up my keys
I asked him what to do and you just
gotta remember that when you got the
boot
money ring your problem will make you
cry sometimes it seems like life is just
a mansion then you die Buddha says
desire you from being free he'll believe
messiahs yet to come gonna judge this
life so well some people believe it
don't mean nothing in and
[Music]
for the pace
and the pants get longer when you got
[Music]
that way
[Applause]
for the case
[Applause]
[Music]
maybe things will get better or when we
reincarnate have so many problems this
class will be fine as long as we don't
get a body Lord
a little shorter won't have so many
[Music]
[Applause]
good good good it works it were the very
happy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
they say your adder will keep moving
even after you're dead they say your
mind keeps moving too laughter it falls
out of your head the scientists will
tell you that nothing dies you can't
stop dancing even if you tries that
birds doing the subatomic shuffle
[Music]
you